is that the one that wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up to the whole show
no no no i'm a comedian i'm a comedian
you're an
audience member that wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up it's her birthday
so what so what i know
i don't talk to people you are such a
jerking number
do you answer them
what is that oh my god
thank you man be my little echo
get out [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you idiot
you're everything that america
should be flushed down the toilet you
[ __ ] turn
[ __ ] you get out get out you [ __ ]
drunk [ __ ]
take her out take her [ __ ] out take
her somewhere that's good
go see [ __ ] madonna you [ __ ] idiot
piece of [ __ ]
[Applause]
you suck buddy i can yell at the
comedian because i'm a drunk gun
that gives me carte launch i got a [ __ ]
and i'm drunk
i can do anything i want i don't have a
[ __ ] i can yell at performers
cause i'm a [ __ ] idiot cause i got a
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] nosy nelly god nobody give
me your time out i'm not your kid
and then she gives me the finger like
she's tanner from the bad news bears
relax why are you involved in their
business
i've been doing this for 19 years yeah i
remember that day
that's how important you are of course i
remember doing letterman carnegie hall
and talking to you
[Applause]
you should be offended by that no i said
you weren't easy to [ __ ]
which you should be offended by because
you [ __ ] should be something that
comes easy
[ __ ] is not something you should
build your life right
easier than giving you the disease by
[ __ ] you was he see
do you do it so
you know what go ahead get it out of
your system because you only have about
six years of cute to get away with this
and then
and then
no really oh no it's just
it's it's just that pretty women have
some sense of
that you know they have us they're
so offended like now i called you pretty
i told you
it would be too hard to [ __ ] now i
called you pretty but that's going to
run out and you're going to have what i
call
you're going to be new ugly when you're
like
36 and you're not gonna know how to deal
with ugly like the rest of us who've
been ugly our whole life
and then all of a sudden you're gonna
walk into a show and you're gonna try
this [ __ ] and they're gonna go
get that pig out of here and they won't
even give you and you're gonna go why
i used to do this all the time it's it's
just what happens when you age
okay all right this is how bad i was in
sex the first time the first time i ever
had sex
[Applause]
glad you remembered
[Applause]
fiance or wife wife wife wife how long
you guys been married
year and a half that's what's up is that
adorable what yo i don't understand that
reaction
why'd you say oh
what was that oh we got one single ass
[ __ ] over there
you suck you hear what she said
y'all missed it she was like i almost
threw up
why are you hating on love with your
lonely ass
you're here by yourself miana's
everybody's uh be honest
not at all you with me with a guy
is that does she have a dick
it's a man or a woman it's a man your
best friend yo he friends on you
that's [ __ ] up huh you know how you
get out of the friend zone
it's real easy you just go like this
one way in one way out baby
[Applause]
look at him he's like yeah you got a
point my man got a point
got some wisdom on stage some wisdom
you guys never hooked up at all
you feel like throwing up a lot why
would you say that he's right next to
you
because oh you play for the other team
oh you're a lesbian
oh all right i see what you're saying
[Applause]
sir are you straight you're straight
okay that's what i actually think we
need to team up a little bit more
straight people are lesbians i mean that
[ __ ] yeah
cause y'all likey and [ __ ] you know
don't you wish you could just hire a
lesbian to tap in when your girl wants a
[ __ ] ate like
like you just go and start it up and
then the second your girl closes her
eyes you're like yo gertrude get in here
handle that [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in there gonna she dive in first
like sonic and
[ __ ] swan dive into the [ __ ] right
when she's about to come
like [ __ ] out of here
so you guys are best friends have you
ever been with a dude
you have how that should go you weren't
into it
why because you didn't come yo
i'ma tell you a little secret most women
don't you know what i mean
it's uh
you might still be straight [ __ ] i'm
just telling this
[Applause]
i'm just saying it like
it's like trying pizza once and be like
i don't like all pizza no
you don't like that slice
well well you okay but like you don't
hate
okay
because i'm trying to understand it this
is what i'm trying to understand like
you like the feeling of a dick
right you must
hold on i got this
you got the [ __ ] aclu in the back
this is
like a dildo looks like a dick not a
[ __ ]
you don't use so you get a pocket [ __ ]
and you just rub it up against your
[ __ ]
like if you really love [ __ ] you would
get a pocket [ __ ] and just scissor that
[ __ ] all night long
yo that's how you know if you're a
four-star lesbian if you got
pocket [ __ ] at the crib bro you've
got a fleshlight just like
[Music]
[Music]
whatever already spitting on the
microphone and all the hepatitis c
i'm going to get from [ __ ] artie's
[ __ ] saliva
oh what's up baby y'all
what's the matter what's the matter with
y'all
are starving and [ __ ] for [ __ ] what's
the matter and [ __ ]
what
all right why are y'all here
like i don't care that [ __ ] don't scare
me
why you want me to meet this [ __ ]
lesbian right here
[Applause]
what's the point like what is the poi
it's wrong because she because i said it
or it's wrong because she's a lesbian
shut up man what kind of [ __ ] is that
that's why this [ __ ] car no one likes
this country because of that goofy [ __ ]
women [ __ ] up everything well you shut
the [ __ ] up
what why
would you think that you should say that
why and no one gives a [ __ ]
why she didn't get mad are you a lesbian
sweetie
you're not a lesbian you you [ __ ] you
you're not a lesbian
[ __ ] my mistake [ __ ]
[Applause]
it ain't like it ain't like people don't
compute
it's the whole stilo like you have a
lesbian steelers not that just a hair
girl
like not just the goofy because it's
like the
[Music]
you're gonna try oh look look at the
[ __ ] save the tuna [ __ ]
looking at me decide ah yeah they
judging me he's me shut the [ __ ] up
this is what women this is why you
should go
i don't you don't have to go home but
just why come to a comedy show
to stick up for a girl that don't need
to be stuck up for
do you understand what i'm saying why
that's so that's my my right to accuse
her of being a lesbian and be wrong
and then you [ __ ] up your friend you're
looking at her
and these these you two do
nothing but ruin everybody's good
[ __ ] time
[Music]
it don't matter dude it really doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter that nobody likes you
even though you
even though you're quite lovely but it's
like you're more annoying than you're
gorgeous
how can that possibly be how can you be
so cute
and i'd like not want to [ __ ] you right
now because you're cause you're
yapping
yeah [ __ ] yeah and you only think you
can yet because you're cute
but no one gives a [ __ ] why would you
defend it
look at the lady you're defending don't
like you does that
does that make
let's let's analyze that let's analyze
that let's just let's just try to figure
out why
she makes no sense the the girl that
you're defending
does not [ __ ] like you
do material shut the [ __ ] up youtube
what is this table
[ __ ] blow off [ __ ] i've been
doing this forever [ __ ]
i could this is my material how about
that i hope
i hope [ __ ] idiots that have
magicians ponytails
and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] 80s [ __ ] i can do this
for an hour and a half
you dumb dick do you even know me like
i i don't even i don't have material
i i had material so she thought that she
should open her [ __ ] trap
and then you and then for some reason
your [ __ ] whipped ass
decided it this is what makes us
all look bad your [ __ ] ponytail are
you
joking me [ __ ] i haven't seen a
ponytail since departures family
you got a ponytail wait a minute and
it's slick
back nobody [ __ ] digs that [ __ ]
not even gay guys any gay guys here
you guys don't even like no [ __ ] like
that
the [ __ ] is wrong with you